if you were on the mat with the squad
what kind of
map talk would you be doing today i'm
not do a you know
let's go we did it you better squat
yes
queen monica sitting before us today in
any nominee six times over for of course
netflix's cheer including unstructured
reality program how are you feeling
we're all just on cloud nine
it's so exciting and i was looking
through every category just to see and
every time i saw a cheer
i was you know scream and get excited so
very well i dressed for the occasion
today i'm in your signature red and
black i even gave you a high pony yay
i am just so excited for you guys you
know the show has
really hit a nerve with people in the
best way possible it's inspiring and it
encourages hard work and dedication
what is it about the show that you think
really just kind of struck a chord with
audiences
um i think it's a lot of things but
basically just
the fact that these kids come together
that have overcome so many hardships in
their life
and they're you know basically just the
fact that you can be successful
no matter what you've overcome or no
matter where you've come from or no
matter what your past is your past does
not define you
and if you surround yourself with the
right people
you can be lifted up and be successful
what has the group chat looked like this
morning have you been facetiming with
the squad who have you spoken with
i actually got to facetime with morgan
because she facetimed me
um but we have been chatting in our
group and everybody is so excited
who's in the group what's everybody been
saying um
ladarius said that we're all welcome for
his
uh role in getting us these emmy
nominations
already already doing his accepted
speech yes he's a mess
so he's just hilarious we just i love to
cut up with them
they just make my day every day so it's
just you know if you need
if you need to be lifted up all you have
to do is say something in the group chat
and
they're just funny those are my kids
i'll
fight tooth and nail for them what would
it mean to you to take home the award
oh my goodness it would it would mean
everything because
you know anytime you get awarded for
something it's
you know like a symbol that you've done
something right
and um you know that's why we work so
hard for these trophies it's not really
for the metal it's really for the
significance of what it means and for
the feeling of
um achieving that success the hard work
that we've put in and i think
you know getting an emmy nomination
is is just like one of these right here
it's you know
the reward the feeling of the symbolism
of success
i would be remiss to not kind of go down
the list and ask you how some of the
members of the squad are doing
how is gabby how was her relationship
with her parents today
great i mean gabby's parents are
fabulous um you know i think you just
have to know them they're
you know they their personalities came
across a little strong in the show and
that's just they're just really fun
people
they love their kids more than anything
um
and you know i mean they're they're
great great parents and
they love you that that family loves
each other
so hard they will they have each other's
back um
so i think you know they got a little
bit of you know short end of the stick
on that as
i was kind of shocked at how people
took them and i guess it's because i
know them so well and i know what great
people they
are um so you know they're they're
really great they're really great people
earlier this year gabby was very honest
and she said you know it was kind of an
eye-opening moment
i feel like all the chaos has brought
positivity
and i feel like we're a lot closer as a
family and i feel like we're
we've always been super good at
communicating but now i feel like it's
just
it's uh even better with my whole entire
family have you noticed anything change
in their dynamic
um you know i've noticed gabby um
she has really come out of her shell and
um you know i think maybe maybe that was
a little bit of the shift you know her
realizing that
um you know instead of allowing them to
do everything for her she needed to kind
of step up and
take charge of some of the things in her
life and she i mean she just
flourished in this whole thing and uh
you know this season when she was back
i just saw her go to a whole nother
level of leadership
and confidence i thought it was great
well speaking of leadership and
confidence a man who could teach a
master class of course
jerry how is he doing have you guys been
in touch
yes jerry is doing fabulous of course
and
uh you know he's always involved in
something um
he i thought i was gonna get to see him
in person
uh he and ladarius and morgan all
graduated in this in the spring
and we had pushed our graduation
ceremony back to
uh august but then we had to end up
canceling that
but he was planning on coming into town
for that so
we'll have to figure out another way for
us to get together and of course
our girl lexi a lot of ups and downs
with her throughout the season and
and with her relationship with you and
with the squad where where does she
stand today how is she doing
i mean once again lexi is also
just has done amazing i think
really really come out of her shell too
and her confidence has just
it's just out the roof i have just
enjoyed watching these kids
you know coming to their own um because
of the show um
lexie will be back here again this next
year
and um she's just doing great
what's been the biggest change that
you've noticed with her
i think just the confidence in herself
and uh
just you know she saw how many people
reached out to her
with support and love and i you know
honestly
those two things can make anyone go to a
whole nother
level of success right i mean when
people believe in you
you believe in yourself and um
i mean i'm just so excited to see what
she does she's
such a brilliant artist and creative
person
and i think she's just got a really
bright future ahead of her
well you mentioned the future the number
one question on
fans minds are we gonna get season two
of cheer what have you heard and are you
down
to be a part of it again oh i'm always
down
i mean i think the whole world needs
more cheer in their life right now but
you know unfortunately i really honestly
don't know so
i'm just gonna enjoy today and just
continue to enjoy season one
and all of the glory that we've gotten
from it
and you know i don't know if i'll stop
smiling today
good you shouldn't you absolutely
deserve to be a glowing goddess all day
i am curious though now now being
somewhat of a
docuseries vet what would you do
differently or what would you want to
see happen in season two that
maybe you didn't get enough of in season
one
you know i that's a good question um
because i i had no idea what to expect
with even you know season one i um
all i could do was just be myself and
do what we normally do and so i don't
think i would do anything differently
just because simply it wouldn't be an
authentic story
if i did anything differently um you
know it took us just
honestly only a few days to get used to
the fact that we had cameras in our
faces
and you know microphones on us on us and
stuff
but um after those first few days
i mean we you know just forget that they
were there we were so focused on what we
were wanting
our you know our goal um for the con
for competition and um so i think if i
did anything different
it would take away a little bit of the
authenticity of the show
so i'm just going to leave it up to you
know
camera people and stuff like that
they're they're the ones that know their
jobs
and and i don't so if um if i was ever
involved in another show
i i would let the experts do their thing
yeah you just keep being you i think
that's really what the fans are looking
for
today you keep going until you
get it right and then you keep going
until you can't get it wrong
this pandemic has really knocked us all
you know on our behinds and the world
has really shifted in in kind of a major
way
i'm curious how does this pandemic
affect
you your work and the state of cheer you
know it ended our season
early uh back in the spring our our
competition our national competition
that we had worked all year for was
canceled just
weeks before um and
did that make you feel it was it was
honestly devastating it
um for so many reasons but
you know we had to meet uh we had taken
a couple days off because we had our
spring break practices where we were
practicing all day
we looked so good we were so prepared
for where we need we were ahead of where
we needed to be
and um they took a few days off and
that's when everything just went kind of
nuts and and things started getting
canceled and every day
this the panic was setting in of you
know what was to come
and that sunday before we were supposed
to meet that following monday for our
next practice uh that's when we found
out our competition was canceled
so we met we had one last meeting to
turn in uniforms
um and basically say goodbye to each
other and that was so hard because we
weren't mentally ready
and just to end that quick i mean we had
several more weeks of memories that we
were supposed to be making together
and to have it was a very sad occasion i
mean i don't even cry that often but
i i cried on the way to the grocery
store i cried on the way to the college
it was just an awful day i took about a
week just to mourn the situation and
really allow myself to be really sad
about it
and then you know just we you've got to
move on so
we just picked ourselves up and moved
forward started working on this year's
team
um working on you know getting things
ready for camp which
got cancelled um and you know so i mean
it
it was tough and i'm looking i'm hopeful
that you know we're going to make the
best out of this year we're going to
definitely um start off our practices a
little differently we're going to try
some
smaller groups so that we can practice
social distancing and be safe about it
and we're just going to take everything
week by week and
you know hopefully by the time the
spring rolls around and we start
preparing for our next
season's competition things will be back
to where we can practice
like we would normally practice